okay I'm considering leaving social
media forever period like just getting
off of social media altogether which is
sort of a difficult thing to do if you
host a show like this one that relies so
much on social media and on being in
touch with people on social media and
using social media to spread the content
that we make and I know that there are
some people in the audience who will
sort of react to this by saying why on
earth would you leave social media but
based on some of the emails I receive
and that's a key word emails I know that
there are lots of people in the audience
who will immediately understand why I'm
thinking of leaving social media
altogether and I could go into sort of
like a long sophisticated explanation of
why but I I don't think I really need to
social media is almost exclusively toxic
as a venue in which people exist and
interact and look at stuff and I'm gonna
kind of build the case up for you one
step at a time
first is the kind of like general
perspective later I'll talk about how it
applies to me as the host of a political
show but Jonathan height for example has
written extensively about the extremely
negative effect of just normal social
media usage on preteens and on high
schoolers at a psychological level and
even for adults the data is more and
more prevalent and overwhelming as far
as this goes which is that spending time
on social media scrolling through your
Facebook feed Twitter feed it's just bad
for our health it's bad for our
psychological health and our physical
health and there's on the one hand the
kind of addictive nature which is
similar to a slot machine just like you
can go back to the slot machine and pull
the lever one more time and maybe you
get something good you can always scroll
down a little bit more down your Twitter
or Facebook feed and you might get
something good and this is this goes
back to operant conditioning this is a
variable reward schedule that applies to
slot machines and it applies to social
media it sort of feels like high school
psychology class this is one of the
things that make social media addictive
and never satisfying because you can
always scroll a little more and maybe
see something even
better or more interesting than the last
thing so that's sort of layer one beyond
that we know that when people scroll
social media you're immediately sort of
automatically starting to compare
yourself with what you see comparing
your life with what's there and when you
compare your life in total with the
curated carefully selected moments and
stories and pictures that other people
are choosing to share it's an impossible
standard and even if we understand this
sort of intellectually as I think most
of us do on a subconscious level it
makes social media really bad for us and
it's not that I spend much time on
social media beyond what's necessary for
the show but there's also the kind of
time element of it if you add up all the
little bits of time that are spent on
Twitter and Facebook and Instagram
looking at a comment here checking out a
comment there it starts to add up and it
gets to what I consider to be sort of
the second layer of the problem if you
haven't read - of Cal Newports books
about this you should immediately read
them Cal Newport wrote the book deep
work years ago and it's about the lack
of what he calls deep work in modern
society people's jobs are increasingly
answering emails administrative tasks
all of what I would call shallow work
that's not actually central to what we
do that is valuable in my case like the
real value the deep work that I'm trying
to do is research and prepare stories
for the show to make the content of the
show as good as possible and the best
way to do this is total concentration no
email checking no social media I want to
be doing more of that more of that deep
work so it seems kind of natural to
eliminate as many of those shallow
behaviors from my day that aren't
totally necessary and social media is
one of them and then Cal Newport also
wrote another book more recently called
digital minimalism which I'll interview
him about in a couple of weeks which
goes beyond just the crisis of the lack
of deep work but it's more about the
damaging effect of most people's social
media use and the payoff is pretty
damn clear to me if I spend an hour
deeply learning about economic theory
that will actually pay dividends for the
show by virtue of me being more informed
for years to come
whereas if I spend that hour scrolling
Twitter and Facebook I might find
another topic or two to discuss on the
show maybe but it's not gonna provide
anything that really improves the show
over the long term so without even
getting specifically to what's going on
with my social media yet which I will
the need for doing deep work the waste
of time that most social media use
represents there's a really solid case
for at least drastically minimizing
social media use to specific moments in
the day which has been my strategy so
far okay so the way I have been sort of
managing this is that I have in my
schedule
as far as work goes in the morning
sometime after I finish up preparing the
day's show I'll check all social
networks I'll respond to what I want to
respond to
I'll make notes about things that I want
to follow up on if there are guest
suggestions people sent me your story
suggestions alright back to personal
messages and then that's it and then
late in the afternoon I'll do another
check but the truth is I have the social
apps on my phone and it's very easy if
I'm on the subway or whatever to just
check in on stuff more often than I'm
kind of consciously trying to so that is
all for everybody that has nothing to do
with my sort of particular situation but
then we get to my social media feed and
it's toxic I mean that's it as many of
you know we get two to three thousand
YouTube comments per day at this point
and I've made it clear that I look at
barely any I mean it's a total cesspool
there's very little benefit other than
I'll look at what videos did well which
videos were heavily liked which videos
were heavily disliked but that's
basically it and unfortunately my
Twitter feed my Facebook feed it has
gotten absolutely horrible and this is
kind of like a curse of success in a
sense the show is now big enough that
any time I go to Twitter
there are dozens if not hundreds of
messages just insults attacks insulting
the show some of its from the right what
really sort of is pushing me towards
maybe abandoning social media all
together is the infighting from the left
people on the left saying this person is
not actually left enough or that person
is too far left or this person is
parroting right wing talking points and
obviously in small doses all of this
stuff is fine but the signal-to-noise
ratio has gotten way way too low in most
of these cases and I had a conversation
with with Sam cedar about this in Vegas
a couple of weeks ago and I said I'm
thinking about it minimum getting off
Twitter if not all social media and he
said just mute people so that you don't
see them which is fine but I have
thousands of people muted on Twitter and
I don't really know that I need to be on
these platforms it seems that there's a
lot to gain from screening them out as
an example like do I need to know that
some guy with a YouTube channel did a 15
minute video attacking me or will I be
basically fine and the show will be just
as good if I focus on my work rather
than looking at who's doing Twitter
posts about me and the only hesitation I
have is that part of the success of the
show is thanks to social media right
social media has been a very important
tool for spreading awareness and the
content of the David Pakman show so it's
weird for me to say I'm completely
getting off of it so I need to think
about it a little bit and in mid-may I'm
gonna be interviewing Cal Newport and
this is one of the things I want to talk
to him about which is does he think I'd
be able to get off of social media given
that this is although it's a radio and
television show it's also significantly
an online show or do I kind of need to
grin and bear it in some sense because
of the importance of social media to the
show maybe I could start looking at just
like verified people's posts on Twitter
but that's problematic because most of
our audience isn't verified on Twitter
so maybe the answer is I just cut it and
I say you know what if you want to get
in touch with me email me actually
take the time to send me an email I
don't know what the answer is but I'm
curious what people think
if you've adopted a sort of digital
minimalism concept into your life I want
to hear about it and one of the really
important things that I want to not
ignore is that whenever people read
about digital minimalism and these types
of issues when people like Cal Newport
write about them the reaction is often a
reflexive that might work for other
people but it wouldn't work for me I
need to be on these platforms because if
X Y Z reason and what I am open to is
the idea that that may just not be the
case like maybe it's not actually that
central to what we're doing so let me
know what you think I want to hear about
your social media use tell me if I'm
completely off on this let me know via
email I would say actually take the time
to write to me and I will eventually I
guess make some kind of decision and let
you know where I land yesterday we
witnessed one of the most stunning and
cartoonish implosions of a public figure
during congressional testimony that I
can remember and I have seen a lot of
examples of this I'm talking about
Donald Trump's propagandizing Attorney
General William bar who testified before
Congress before a Senate committee and
imploded in a way that is really a a
data point in recent political history
extraordinarily notable now the entire
thing went on for hours and I'm not
going to play hours of testimony for you
and there are actually lots of clips I
could show you a Senator mazie Hirono
did very very well
some other senators did very well but
just for today just to take sort of a
tour of one moment of this testimony I'm
gonna focus in on Senator Kamala Harris
as questioning of bar which exposed some
major problems in the building evidence
against Barr as not a law enforcement
official but just as a partisan actor in
this entire Moeller report fiasco who
should immediately be impeached for his
role in the management of the Moller
investigation and the release of the
report Barr refused to even answer
clearly like it started and it was
already bad Kamala Harris just asking a
yes-or-no question
and bar refusing to answer whether Trump
or people around Trump have directed bar
to investigate specific people which
we're going to get into in a bit
William bar admitted that he made the
decision not to charge President Trump
with obstruction without having looked
at the evidence of the investigation
which in and of itself there's some
justification for and I'll talk about
that
but it opened the door to bar suggesting
that maybe part of the decision not to
charge Trump was made by rod Rosenstein
which is extremely problematic since
Rosenstein was a witness in that
investigation stunning conflict of
interest that bar admitted to a witness
in an investigation shouldn't get to
decide whether that investigation leads
to charges it's a total miscarriage of
justice and I hate to have to do this
last disclaimer here but I have to
because of the political environment in
which we are finding ourselves
I'm telling you that Kamala Harris
crushed bar in this hearing because she
did I'm not endorsing her for president
this is not an attack on Bernie who I
like just skip it okay if you're gonna
write to me and your reaction to this
will be I'm now a shill for Kamala
Harris
she crushed Barr and that's what we're
talking about here so check out Barr
squirming mealy-mouthed unable to even
deny that the White House is telling him
who to investigate and notice that if
you're watching cory booker is sitting -
Kamala Harris is right the smirk on his
face is the smirk of I am watching
something really really good happen
right here here's Barr starting to
implode on national television Thank You
mr. chairman attorney general Barr has
the President or anyone at the White
House ever asked or suggested that you
open an investigation of anyone I
wouldn't I wouldn't yes or no could you
repeat that question I will repeat it
has the president or anyone at the White
House ever asked or suggested that you
open an investigation of anyone yes or
no please sir the President or anybody
else seems you would remember something
like that and be able to tell us yeah
but I'm trying to grapple with the word
suggest I mean
there have been discussions of matters
out there that they have not asked me to
open a investigation but perhaps they've
suggested I don't know I wouldn't say
suggest hinted I don't know inferred you
don't know okay yeah the answer that he
doesn't know is stunning and I don't
really get why Kamala Harris moves on at
this point I would have continued on
that but I also get that she had other
things to get to in limited time but
stunning and relevant because there are
suspicions that Trump is pushing the
Justice Department to open
investigations into people involved with
the Moller probe into Hillary Clinton
Hillary Clinton associates who knows and
bar doesn't deny it here already
extraordinary and the look on Cory
Booker's face that smirk really says it
all so let's continue and this is really
key Kamala Harris gets to a really
important point Barr and Rosenstein put
out a statement saying that the evidence
led them to decide not to charge Donald
Trump with obstruction but Kamala Harris
wants to know did you actually look at
the evidence and the answer is of course
no March 24th summary you wrote that
quote after reviewing the special
counsels final report Deputy Attorney
General Rosenstein and I have concluded
that the evidence is not sufficient to
establish that the president committed
an obstruction of justice offense now
the special counsels investigation
produced a great deal of evidence I've
led to believe it included witnesses
notes and emails witnesses congressional
testimony witnesses interviews which
were summarized in the FBI 302 forms
former FBI director Comey's memos and
the president's public statements my
question is in reaching your conclusion
did you personally review all of the
underlying evidence no we took an
accepted did we accepted mr. Rosen sign
no we accepted the statements in the
report as the factual record we did not
go underneath it to see whether or not
they were accurate we accepted it as
accurate and made our say you are
accepted the report as the evidence
yes you did not question or look at the
underlying evidence that supports the
conclusions in the report no so let's
talk about this think back for a second
to when the bar letter was released the
report was sent to bar and within 48
hours bar was able to say we're not
indicted how did he decide so quickly
and Trumpets wrote to me and said well
David obviously William bar got the
report way in advance and had time to
look at all the underlying evidence in
that report and here is William bar
himself saying actually no he didn't
look at the evidence before deciding not
to prosecute he did it based on the
Muller report which actually says there
is substantial evidence of obstruction
so I want to be really careful here okay
because some law enforcement officials
reached out to me because I talked about
this on my live stream last night and
said David hold on a second
it's not crazy for Barr not to look at
the underlying evidence imagine as Rob
for example wrote to me imagine a murder
investigation where somebody got shot
the report says the shooters
fingerprints were on the gun the
Attorney General wouldn't necessarily go
to evidence and look at the fingerprints
themselves they would just assume
because this is how things work that the
report claiming the finger prints were
found is good enough and that's a
perfectly reasonable point but there's a
couple caveats here that you have to
think about number one the report said
there is substantial evidence of
obstruction so when William Barr says I
didn't actually look at the evidence to
make that decision well the report said
there was substantial evidence so when
you don't go and look at the evidence
for yourself and you make a decision
that seems to run directly counter to
what was contained in the report that
starts to be problematic but then
there's another kind of issue here which
is the whole point is Muller didn't say
that he recommends or can exonerate
Trump from charges on obstruction
normally when an AG or a state's
attorney prosecutor whatever get a
report the report says on the basis of
the evidence here's our recommendation
as to what you should do indict or not
indict this was left up to bars so the
standard is different with
guard 2 bars responsibility to look at
to actually look at the evidence now
this is all just a lead-up because this
gets us to Kamala Harris saying isn't it
a problem that you made a decision about
charging the president or not charging
the president without looking at the
evidence and bar tries to play this game
of well go ask Bob Muller because in the
end he's the prosecutor
I'm just the Attorney General at which
point Kamala Harris says well you did
make the decision not Muller right and
bar gets visibly confused and it becomes
unclear who actually made this decision
and it is barred digging the hole deeper
he ties himself up into a pretzel and
then big mistake he mentions will
actually rod Rosenstein was involved in
this decision which we'll get to in a
second take a look as the Attorney
General of the United States
you run the United States Department of
Justice if in any US Attorney's Office
around the country the head of that
office when being asked to make a
critical decision about in this case the
person who holds the highest office in a
land
and whether or not that person committed
a crime would you accept them
recommending a charging decision to you
if they had not reviewed the evidence
well that's a question for Bob Muller
he's the US attorney he's the one who
presents the report but it was you who
made the charging decision sir you made
the decision not to charge the president
in a memo and in a declination memo you
said it was your baby what did you mean
by that
it was my baby to look to let to decide
whether or not to disclose it to the
public and whose decision was it who had
the power to make the decision about
whether or not the evidence was
sufficient project make a determination
of whether there had been an obstruction
of justice
prosecution memos go up to the
supervisor in this case it was the
attack you know the Attorney General and
the Deputy Attorney General who decide
on the final decision what does is mean
what is language how does English work
I'm so confused how did I get here and
there he said it he talks about the
Deputy Attorney General so Bar opens the
door to rod Rosenstein with
Kamala Harris gets to and this is the
key moment okay and you're gonna be
confused about what William Bar says in
this next clip because it doesn't make
any sense
did rod Rosenstein decide on prosecuting
or not prosecuting trump on obstruction
of justice and if he did Rosenstein was
a witness in that probe why is a witness
in the probe deciding about whether
there will or will not be prosecutions
was he cleared to be making those
decisions ask Kamala Harris and William
Barse says I don't know I suppose he was
cleared or maybe not this is what a liar
looks like be the conflict you know I
haven't been the only decision-maker
here now let's take the Deputy Attorney
General rod Rosenstein who was approved
by this Senate 94 to 6 with specific
discussion on the floor that he would be
responsible for supervising the Russian
investing I'm glad you brought up that
that's a great start heirs experience
and we had a number of senior
prosecutors in my department involved in
this process both career and non-career
yes I have another question and I'm glad
you brought that subject up because I
have a question about that earlier today
in response to Senator Graham you said
quote that you consulted with Rosenstein
constantly unquote with respect to the
special counsels investigation or report
but Deputy Attorney General Rosenstein
is also a key witness in the firing of
FBI director Comey did you consult with
D I'm not finished did you consult with
DOJ ethics officials before you enlisted
rod Rosenstein to participate in a
charging decision for an investigation
the subject of which he is also a
witness my understanding was that he had
been cleared already to participate in
it but so you had consulted with them
and they cleared it no I think they
cleared it when he when he took over the
investigation did you can I understand
you don't know whether he's been cleared
of a conflict of interest he would be
participating if there was a conflict of
interest so you're saying that it did
not need to be reviewed by the career
ethics officials in your office I
believe I believe it was well I believe
it was reviewed and I and will also
point out this scene
to be a bit of a flip-flop because when
the president's observers were checking
this that you're not answering the
question directly did the ethics
officials in your office in the
Department of Justice review the
appropriateness of Rodd Rosenstein being
a part of making a charging decision on
an investigation which he is also a
witness in yeah Mike so as I said my
understanding was he had been cleared
and he had been cleared before I arrived
[Laughter]
endlessly endlessly stunning this is
what a liar looks like bars a hatchet
man he did what he was brought in to do
it's very clear now and he has to be
removed let me know what you think I'm
on Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
twitter at david pakman show i want to
hear from you about this let's talk now
about Donald Trump's position on a lot
of this stuff for someone who says that
he doesn't want to get impeached Donald
Trump is really behaving like someone
who is trying to get Democrats to
impeach him we've been talking a lot
about the growing demands for Trump's
impeachment we've been talking about
Trump's behavior exposed by the Muller
report we've been talking about the
strategy behind impeachment does it make
sense strategically we've talked about
the ethics behind it but there is a
completely separate issue that is
growing here which is that Donald
Trump's actions in the last two weeks
are starting to force the hands of
Democrats who may end up with no
credible option but to impeach the
President of the United States and if
you're wondering what what is Trump been
doing for the last couple of weeks David
I will tell you what he's been doing the
third article of impeachment against
Richard Nixon I mentioned this in the
last segment we already talked about it
Donald Trump is increasingly sort of in
contempt of Congress Donald Trump has
directed his administration straight up
to fight every congressional subpoena to
stonewall every request from Congress
and to make it as close to impossible as
they can for an actual investigation to
take place even Nancy Pelosi who said
she's against impeachment that Trump's
not worth impeachment which angered a
lot of Democrats when she
said it and I think it was March even
Nancy Pelosi said we have to investigate
before we can even say if impeachment is
on the table and Trump is blocking every
single request that's part of that
investigation and this is a huge part of
why more and more Democrats are now
talking about impeachment I already told
you last week Elizabeth Warren Kamala
Harris Elijah Cummings maxine waters
george w bush's former speechwriter aoc
a mix of people in and out of elected
office now Donald Trump is stonewalling
investigations and more names are adding
themselves to the list congressman Jamie
Raskin current member of Congress says I
have a hunch that he is moving the whole
caucus closer to seeing impeachable
offenses what is Trump stonewalling so
far
Trump AG William Barr might not show up
to testify Trump directed all records
requests from the Oversight Committee to
be fought this is the job of the
Oversight Committee and the president is
obstructing them from being able to do
that job the house Intel committee is
trying to look into Donald Trump's
finances the administration is ignoring
all requests the Justice Department
hasn't even responded to document
requests Trump a rather top Justice
Department lawyer John Gore is going to
ignore a subpoena to testify
I challenge so-called constitutional
conservatives who say they believe in
checks and balances put in place by the
founders to just announce this okay if
you're a trumpet of moral substance
maybe there are some out there I want to
hear from you contact me and tell me you
like Trump you want Trump reelected you
love his tax cuts for the rich or
whatever tell me that we have checks and
balances in this country for a reason
and that Donald Trump cannot continue
his behavior here the founders created
the people's house to prevent exactly
this type of autocratic authoritarian
despotism okay despot is a ruler who
holds absolute power typically one who
exercises it in a
cruel or oppressive way Trump doesn't
actually have absolute power but unless
someone stops him from behaving as if he
does he has effectively pragmatically
absolute power and Trump is doing this
by saying screw the law screw the
separation of powers I'm just not going
to let the house do what it was created
to do and so much of what the founders
did was meant to stop presidents from
being above the law when the special
counsel says we had substantial evidence
we had 11 possible obstruction counts
but it's politically messy to indict a
president that makes the president above
the law when the house does the right
thing they request documents the correct
way in order to investigate and the
White House says nah no documents no
testimony that becomes a White House
that is above the law it's not what
Madison wanted it's not what the
founders wanted and this is actually
bigger than Trump which is why I'm sort
of waiting maybe stupidly maybe naively
I'm waiting for the constitutional
conservatives to say we've had it maybe
we voted for Trump
maybe Hillary would have been worse in
their eyes of course but this is about
the foundational principles of the
country and whether they matter anymore
the right wants these constitutional
fights around like the Second Amendment
which guns can we have based on the
Second Amendment forget for a second
that we have a constitutional right here
that is even more important and it's
about whether the president is totally
immune from consequences for their
actions the founders gave us the tools
impeachment congressional investigations
congressional subpoenas Trump is
ignoring them all and if he's allowed to
do it with no consequences then he is
effectively an unchecked autocrat I'm
ready for the constitutional
conservatives to say no more but I have
a feeling I'm gonna be waiting around
for a long time and that voting in
November of 2020 is going to be a much
faster remedy but I'll say it again if
you're at rumpus Teddy to take the right
moral position and say this can't
continued checks-and-balances can't be
ignored and flout it in this way get in
touch with me I want to hear from you
make sure you're following the David
Pakman show on instagram at david pakman
show we will have a poll related to this
before you know it while you're there
also follow me i'm on instagram at david
pakman we'll take a quick break and be
back after this there's this saying that
money can't buy you class think you
already know where this is going there's
been no person who better embodies money
can't buy you class than Donald Trump
and he decided once again to pull this
stunt where he invites a college sports
team to the White House after a big win
and he serves them fast food and this
started when he had a team at the White
House during the government shutdown a
college football team and it became sort
of a stunt that since government was
shut down Trump sent people at the White
House out to go get fast food pizza and
burgers and fries and serve them to the
players and of course right-wingers love
that it's so down to earth it's so
man-of-the-people
but anybody with common sense actually
found it pretty disgusting now for years
Donald Trump has never invited a women's
championship team of any kind to the
White House he finally did it with the
Baylor University women's basketball
team and Trump served them fast food he
weirdly mentioned when they gave him a
commemorative Jersey that said Trump on
it that he loves how jerseys show off
their beautiful arms which was a strange
moment that we'll get to and then he
gave a very brief statement in the Oval
Office surrounded by the team and he
took it as an opportunity to brag about
himself and the Oval Office and as usual
a speech that I guess was supposed to be
about them
Trump is able to make about him so first
of all here's a video from one of the
players or coaches who posted it to
Instagram just laughing at the fact that
there's there's yet another one of these
fast food spreads at the White House
like wow he was not lying Pete though
right now this is already so lacking in
class that the story could just be about
serving fast food to athletes athletes
that are at the top of their game the
football team got fast food if they want
to get fast food on their own okay but
for the President of the United States
to serve elite athletes fast food is
insulting
it's disgusting it sets a horrible
example about what it means to eat a
reasonably good diet these are athletes
who are training to play their sport at
the top level they come to the White
House to celebrate an achievement that
they made in athletics at least in part
because of the training and the
nutrition and the discipline that went
into it and you serve them the
equivalent of poison right you serve him
the equivalent of food poison lacking in
total class and decorum and it could be
all about that it could be about a
billionaire serving elite athletes cheap
burgers and fries but there's much more
here the Baylor women's team gathered
behind Donald Trump in the Oval Office
and Trump started speaking in his
typical ignorant way and it very quickly
became about him and about the Oval
Office and there was not a smile in the
room the players genuinely look angry
and confused about what Trump is saying
many of them look completely miserable
and if you're just listening it's bad
and if you're watching it's even worse
take a look he used to come and gonna be
looking back and you're gonna be
thinking about that incredible season
and you're gonna be thinking about being
in this incredible office right this is
the Oval Office this is where it all
begins and ends and then begins again
Lily right this is a very special place
I've had the biggest people in the world
come into this office and they stop and
they look and actually some I have had
this too strong tough people start
crying can you believe it I've seen them
where they cry and it's pretty amazing
but that's where you are right now this
is the Oval Office
so to say you know they say this is sort
of the ball game
right this is the ball money has
definitely not bought Donald Trump any
class and then here's Trump talking
about the beautiful arms that are
exposed by basketball jerseys adding
weirdness to an already completely
classless moment first of all thank you
for inviting us and we would like to
present you with one of our jerseys it
may not be the right size so maybe he's
joking about his own arms who knows what
he's even saying but it's a national
embarrassment truly and they shouldn't
even have gone to the White House and
for people who don't know much about
Baylor University it's actually a
right-wing religious school where up
until recently if you disclosed that you
were gay or lesbian you you were you
were not allowed to be there I mean you
were punished you were held that I don't
remember the exact specifics of it but
they recently changed a rule that just
banned gay people from saying that they
are gay and they have their fair share
of problems but it's still hard to
imagine that the players like Donald
Trump and going from the sort of macro
to the micro it's one embarrassment
after another it's like it's trade deals
or it's lying about having spoken to
OPEC and the Saudis about oil oil prices
or it's inviting a college sports team
to the White House and serving them
fast-food and talking all about yourself
the world continues to laugh at us
because of this buffoon and we've got to
get them out and we have 19 months until
we can actually make a vote that that
will do exactly that make sure you're
following me on Instagram at David
Pakman and make sure you following the
david pakman show on instagram as well
at david pakman show a lot of great
stuff including behind the scenes
pictures and much much more
we'll take a break and next I will tell
you about an app that allows Saudi
men to track the physical whereabouts of
their wives that's coming up next
every day that goes by there is less of
a debate as to whether Donald Trump
obstructed justice the debate is how
badly how brazenly did Donald Trump
obstruct justice is there any way to
make Donald Trump face consequences for
obstructing justice and is Donald Trump
going to get away with obstruction of
justice and along these lines over the
weekend we learned that prosecutors
working for Robert Muller are now saying
yes Donald Trump obstructed justice
there's a bombshell article in The New
York Review of Books which points out
that this is not even a recent
conclusion that molars prosecutors came
to so let's take a step back and reset
so that we all have all of the necessary
information here in the Muller report
Muller
wrote that there was quote substantial
evidence that Donald Trump obstructed
justice but that ultimately Muller did
not move to indict the president because
of the legal mess that indicted a
sitting president would create and
because it would interfere with Donald
Trump being able to carry out his duties
of the presidency if he were to be
indicted that's horrifying okay
these were political reasons not to
indict Donald Trump for obstruction not
legal reasons but let's take a step back
from that for a second we've now learned
that two prosecutors working for Robert
Muller concluded last year that they had
evidence to indict Donald Trump for
obstruction specifically for pressuring
former FBI director James Comey before
he fired him to end the investigation
into Michael Flynn
once again they said we had the evidence
that Trump should be indicted but
because of the complexity of indicted a
sitting president we didn't go forward
with that indictment this is all in an
article written over the weekend by
Murray wasps in the New York Review of
Books based on what two of Robert
Muller's prosecutors told other law
enforcement officials this eventually
became Donald Trump's hand-picked
attorney General William Bar saying I'm
not going to charge Donald Trump with a
crime obviously
wasn't a surprise and this is how you
get a president out of trouble which
William bar is an expert in doing
William Bar has been getting presidents
out of trouble for decades and now it
goes beyond just pressuring Comey to end
the probe into Michael Flynn there are
if you looked at the molar report and if
you haven't and you're writing to me
about it
what are you doing read the molar report
there are eleven instances of possible
obstruction by Donald Trump in the molar
report another example was when Trump
tried to fire Robert Muller he told
White House Counsel Don began going fire
Robert Muller
Don McGann just straight-up refused
realizing that that was a disastrous
idea there are other examples of Trump
obstructing justice trying to for
example influence or intimidate
witnesses against him so this is how it
happens unless you actually do the work
if you don't read the Moller report if
you don't go and do the investigative
journalism you're just like a normal
person who lives your life you're busy
earning a paycheck you're busy getting
your kids to school you hear like 1% of
the story you hear two year
investigation Trump said no obstruction
no collusion William Barr said it front
bragged about it that's basically all
the information you get but when you dig
into it you realize that Muller went out
of his way in the report multiple times
to say he can't clear Trump obstruction
meaning there is a ton of evidence of
obstruction there is a ton of evidence
that Donald Trump is a criminal obstruct
or and remembered that Robert Miller
actually wrote quote if we had
confidence after a thorough
investigation of the facts that the
president clearly did not commit
obstruction of justice we would so state
the evidence we have state obtained
about the president's actions and intent
presents difficult issues that prevent
us from conclusively determining that no
criminal conduct occurred if you don't
take the time to look and to read this
stuff and it's okay most Americans don't
because they have lives that don't
revolve around legal documents in
Washington DC they think Trump has been
totally cleared they actually believe
he's
Zana rated but if you go back and you
look at the evidence and you look at
reports and testimony you realize that
there is criminal obstruction that
prosecutors believed they'd found
criminal obstruction but they didn't
indict because it's politically
difficult to indict a president William
bar propagandized this into no crime
Trump's a victim and that's the
narrative that Trump and his advisors
and his aides and Fox News have been
running with so what needs to happen now
number one the House of Representatives
has to subpoena Robert Muller and has to
subpoena the prosecutors to get them to
say this under oath you've got to
establish that under oath the only
reason there wasn't an indictment
against against Trump is that he's the
president and you've got to get that in
testimony and William bar needs to be
held accountable for repeatedly making
false characterizations of what
investigators concluded this is not a
political game okay
this is the foundation on which the
country is built and some of the most
important questions that can be asked
need to be asked is the president immune
from criminality are there are they more
like an unchecked monarch in practice or
is this still the United States of
America as originally designed and for
people who were saying but David it's
legalese in the report it should have
been made more clear if Trump actually
obstructed justice for legal language
this is as clear as it gets for each of
the eleven counts they talk in the
report about the elements that are
needed to show obstruction and they say
we cannot clear Trump if we could clear
him we would say it that's in the report
and then bars interpretation makes it
all seem inconclusive makes it
impossible to really know wrong forget
about what Barr said the report says
here's evidence of obstruction in eleven
instances some of them have more
evidence some of them have less the
Justice Department doesn't indict
sitting presidents but we cannot clear
Trump and by the way there's a very
interesting foot
footnote 10 90 or 10 91 of the report
which says impeachment does not
substitute indictment after the
president is no longer in office and
we're going to talk about that tomorrow
but the media fell for it
they were very easily manipulated
Americans are busy living their lives
they're not going to be going and
looking at the footnotes of a 448 page
report and they did it they got away
with it unless something changes and
it's it's a truly sick reality that we
are likely going to have to deal with
the remedy being voting in 2020 as we
always knew that it would be let me know
what you think I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman and the show is on Twitter at
David Pakman show